let's go to our next caller from the
seven eight one area code caller from
seven eight one what's your name where
you're calling from hey that's me
that is you hi David I'm Matt I'm
calling from Massachusetts all right go
ahead Matt I just wanted to know what's
the best way to contact you about
something I just wanted to talk to you
about something that I don't really feel
like putting over-the-air but I just
wanted like send you an email or
something okay I mean it's it's it's so
great that we're talking now because we
could just do it you know what I mean
and nobody knows who you are anyway it's
just there's a million Matt's you sure
you don't want to just talk about it
right now
yeah I kind of want to just send it over
email so I'm just kind of embarrassed to
talk about it really could you give me
like what umbrella would it be under is
it is it like a is it a political issue
that a family issue as a sexual issue
romance um probably a financial issue I
play okay and is this a personal issue
or something you're asking for a friend
personal okay well what if you just said
it was for a friend and you asked me
okay I mean listen I'm gonna be honest
with you I'm too busy to get into
back-and-forth s-- on email with people
like you know everyday we get hundreds
of emails hundreds of tweets so I'm not
able to engage in the back-and-forth
directly unfortunately the show it's a
blessing and a curse that the show has
gotten so big that I need to do the
political discussion and and those
conversations on the show and it would
be great if I could engage one-on-one in
that way but it's just not practical so
I would say listen nobody knows who you
are you could be anybody your name might
not even really be Matt I would take the
opportunity and ask me now but if that's
not something you want to do maybe there
let me ask you a different question Matt
why is it that you've identified me as
the person to help with this issue wait
that again how did you Wyatt why am I
the person to help you with your issue
rather than anybody else I don't know I
just feel you a really nice guy no all
right well I would love to help you I
don't know where to go with this Pat I
would love to help you but you know we
you can email in of course but we were
not able i I do
the discussion on the show you know
alright no worries okay alright sorry I
couldn't help you man I'm so curious I
got to be very austere yeah there's
nothing can can you tell us what type of
financial issue it is generally if you
were to categorize it No
Wow Wow like what could it even make a
change of some sort does he want to
offer you money for what could even be
embarrassing is it I mean if you made a
bad financial decision that's nothing to
be embarrassed about it's something to
figure out you know yeah I'm just yeah
alright Matt sorry sorry that we're not
able to discuss it in more detail
no worries everyone all right you too
geez that's a mysterious mysterious in
many ways don't know what that's about